thank you
[Music]
welcome to the eviction 2022.
over the next few weeks you're going to
have a series of very intense property
investment challenges and the winner is
going to be given 20 000 pounds cash
prize to help kick-start your property
investment Journey
with the help of various mentors that
are going to be assisting me throughout
these challenges I'll decide who stays
and who gets evicted
because you needed to be spoon-fed wow
just don't lie to me don't call me a
liar I'm not gonna lie down and take it
can I have a break
better than Coronation Street isn't it
you're evicted
[Music]
congratulations you made it through to
Challenge three so far you've done
pretty well this next challenge is going
to be the hardest that we've done yet
and by the end of this challenge there's
only going to be four of you left
because there's going to be two people
evicted which is going to mean that the
20 000 pounds cash prize is looking very
very close for some of you
last challenge you package and sold
deals and you made between two teams
made 42 000 pounds which is fantastic
Jody absolutely killed it the fire came
through so we want to see that Adam
a little bit on the brink so this is
going to be your chance to really prove
yourself and want to see you as an
incredibly strong contestant in this
challenge
[Music]
this challenge is not about selling
deals this is about finding the dream
property investment the creme of the
creme and in the market right now the
Market's hot the Market's popping so it
isn't easy to find these deals but
you're going to be looking for a
property number one that's going to give
you super high cash flow so I want you
to find something that's not just a
single family home I want you to find a
property that can run or can be
converted into a house of multiple
occupancy second thing is I want you to
find a property that you can add
significant value to I want you to find
the worst house on the best street
meaning if you were to buy it you could
then refinance it remortgage it and pull
all your investment out
in terms of area
I want you to find something either in
London or around surrounding areas of
London and the winning team is going to
be the team that finds the best property
investment HMO by refurbished refinance
good cash flow so your teams are going
to be Adam
and Jody and Adriana
Scott and Matt
Scott you're going to be team leader of
your team I know you've got a little bit
of experience in refurbishments so your
time to shine Adam you weren't that good
in the last challenge you almost got
evicted so this is your chance to really
show us What You're Made Of on being
team leader of this challenge now in
total you have 48 hours
to bring me your secured deal I want it
off the market wrapped up offer accepted
and once you've secured your deal in 40
hours you're going to be
presenting your investment opportunity
in front of 200 property investors and
I'm going to be taken into account your
communication skills your deal how well
you work as a team but don't forget yes
you work as a team but ultimately this
is going to be strongest contestants get
through so prove yourselves you've got
48 hours
off you go
the way I work and the way I've always
worked is there's three things we're
shopping determine the the outcome of a
goal so the first one is is work great
the second one is like your attitude or
your mindset and the third one's your
ability so I think everyone here
obviously very good ability and it's
very tight with using the other team
we come back and and they sat down there
then we keep going until they go bad we
keep going sleep is for the week yeah
[Music]
I'm excited to be team leader because
we've got a fantastic team this is kind
of what I do in my investing so yeah I'm
very confident we're going to win I'm
nervous a little bit for the pitch I
haven't really done public speaking
before but I'm sure if if we've got a
good deal in front of us I don't think
there's any reason to be nervous
whatsoever
first things first I think
um Memphis first off try and find the
location
yeah I mean I think mine's got
altercation in the last challenges it's
sort of been hanged out and we've sort
of come over it we both know
that with strong characters and Scott's
gonna put his point across and we put
Mark pointing across but now we're
working together quite well I think
[Music]
so what do you want to do with areas do
you want to designate one area and we
stick with that area because I don't
want to get clouded I think one or two
areas yeah 100 choose an area maybe do
it for half an hour hour until we get to
the point where I'm finding anything or
not what areas jumping out to you guys
we need to just make sure what hasn't
got our article full direction as soon
as we find that out then we'll go from
need you to get onto the council
straight away and find out where our
floor is yeah yeah I mean it's massive
place isn't it let me just see if I can
get it up on Google Article 4 is areas
where you need to have a license to have
HMO what we really want to find is a
property outside of alcohol and the
fringes so that way you can then set it
up as a HMO and then get grandfather
rights so that boosts the value of the
property as well once that happens well
I mean what's your thoughts on like a
HMO that's already licensing or one
that's a really functioning the HMO we
don't want to go in and buy a HMO really
we want to be looking to buy a home that
we can convert to a HMO we want to be
able to pull our money out this is a bro
with an exit strategy of a HMO not buy a
HMO and then you sell that we need to be
able to pull our money back out it's
quite straightforward to convert yeah
you know it's just it's more the
legalities isn't it it's the fire doors
and the fire systems and yeah what sort
of size properties are we thinking vegan
because where's got to go for planning
if we can stick under seven so let's say
we found a free bed and we can convert
it into a six bed yeah and then we was
getting around the room at six grand a
month yeah yeah do you know what I mean
ideally should we start there and then
yeah I think it'll be easier looking for
a three-bedroom big reception rooms yeah
it may be free yeah
oh you're looking smart
as well today's Samuel has sent me here
to check up on the team and make sure
they're actually doing what they're
supposed to be doing because it's a
tough challenge you know it's really
hard finding a good deal in just a few
days and then getting ready to pitch it
in front of investors it's going to be
tough but I'm hopeful I mean I'm
expecting to walk in and they will be on
the phone booking viewings how many
viewings you got uh two silver and what
happens if this one cancels that one
cancels scrap it off what would your
plan be my plan would be booking as many
views as you can today yes today for
tomorrow yes yes yeah yeah even today if
you can get some today yeah like all of
this stuff I mean geez great
yeah this is good but this stuff you
want to be looking at after you've done
the viewing
[Applause]
fabulous you look great thank you so how
is everyone how are you getting on yeah
we're good we've got high energy so this
one is going to be really hard challenge
because they have to find valuation they
have to get all the reports for the car
stuff and they literally only have two
days
so for this challenge to really win it
they need to be ringing they shouldn't
be doing any due diligence at this point
if it was me I'd just go and ring ring
ring and just book a viewings if it was
me I'd want to be on the phone all three
of yous you want to be on the phone
Non-Stop
do you know what your biggest problem is
going to be worrying too much
your biggest problem is just going to be
sat there thinking oh do we need
planning is it going to be I forget it
just ring some leads just ring them and
speak to him because if you've only got
a couple of views at the moment I mean
geez if they cancel it you know you've
got nothing to show for it apart from
you know all of these Bits of Paper
which is just pointless at the moment
hi good morning I'm just calling about
the property you've got available on
Walnut Tree Road in Heston first
question needs to be is it in auction is
the property an auction property what if
you've got anything else on your books
that sort of mattresses that criteria
maybe do a bit of Renovations on add a
bit of value yeah it needs to be quick
I'm looking to move quickly you see so
why is no one on the phone every time I
walk in here somebody needs to be on the
phone
[Music]
location wise they're just all over the
place no one knows where they're looking
it's things in our areas the problem is
London's massive so I'm thinking maybe
really we should be drawn out of London
a little bit we probably should have
gone with Oxford like you said initially
then I don't even know where they're
looking at so you know I don't know how
they're going to work as a team but out
of all the contestants I think
cherelle's doing really good because
she's got the two viewings so is that
available to view today 315 that sounds
awesome Jody she's just been to all
talks but you know she hasn't really got
anything
not available at the moment I'm in quite
a rush and I've literally got two days
whilst I'm in like someone else honestly
wasting time
I know the pressure's on Adam at the
moment as a team leader to just raise
the energy up and just stand up and just
have a smile on your face it'll make so
much difference you tell me not to be
too nice and you tell me your spinal I
want you guys to mental we just need to
be on it
3 30 is perfect so I can do this evening
around 6 15. it's starting to get a bit
more you know energy about them now but
what concerns me is there's just no
leadership when your team leader you've
got to take control you've got to be
able to delegate tasks tell them what
you want doing and it's just not taking
any control if you want to win this
challenge he's got to stop being a true
team leader do you have an idea which
one you're going to be pitching to the
investors we've got not yet we've got
one or two in mind though how'd you not
know bro she knows you don't you're a
team leader you're a team leader you're
better than that bro take some control
take some leadership
so it's going to be really challenging
but whoever can do it will be worth the
20 000 pounds you've got to take that in
there with you from the start okay
because wasting time
[Music]
we've been a bit disjointed but we're
gonna fix that and work better as a team
we've managed to secure two viewings
it's not the area that I'm most set on
we don't have to do it if we try and go
to reading or Oxford or something like
that and we can't get any viewings and
we've missed out on the two viewings
yeah so I've made a decision we're going
to go for the viewings because one might
be better than none it's going to happen
we're good it only takes one
what's the sketch with this has this
been has this been put through with
plotting this has got planning so you
can send over the planning documents
yeah just as long as all these things
have all got plans and stuff oh we're
about to go through here
at my house I don't want to show you
please exactly
come through no you know it's my house
okay it's not like this my friend George
show us around I will show you around
but you know my way not your way can you
go back yes of course cancer
wasting time
don't worry this ain't gonna work we'll
arrange another viewing it's convenient
okay Jesus Christ that was awful wasn't
it everything that that London I was
doing that is completely illegal that's
awful so basically that landlord in
there who's running basically uh
effectively an HMR the building at the
back is bottom is is nowhere near to
building regulations or control so the
full building the back would have to be
knocked down and built to building
standards that's what we want at worst
viewers in fact that is the worst
viewing I've ever done in my entire life
huge amount of space we can easily get
free bedrooms down here it's being sold
for a three bedroom but we can convert
it into a six bedroom so the uplift on
that is just incredible these little
insects potentially there's like room
for showers and stuff like that you can
eat into that space and build an ensuite
into the corner of the room but out here
is quite exciting as well we come down
to the garden and we've seen that
someone next door is built and Annex out
the back so they're allowed to do it and
next door have done it there's no reason
why we can't do it the house could be
renovated to a six bed so you can go
straight away straight away HMO is ready
and then you know if you're wanting to
build up your Capital then you could
build these out after whilst you put
planning in so literally we're in a
position where we can get this ready to
go without having to wait for plan and
everything the potential risk is that it
will have article four in the area and
it won't have grandfather rights I mean
it's not on existing hmoke as you can
tell and then obviously that will mock
up our strategy which is brr to HMO but
we've still got stuff in the pipeline as
well we've got other areas other
properties to see one of these is going
to come in quiz in
what we really want to find is something
that we could buy put money in but then
also then refinance and get most of our
money back out it's a jungle out here
you're telling me within probably last
12 months that was functioning the
windows are looking okay
come on
[Music]
all right
we've got seven viewing foot today got
my pet lunch I'm ready I'm ready to go
come on let's go I think last night we
stayed up world one trying somehow to
make the numbers work we just couldn't
get the evaluations so we've been
resulting moving out a London Branch
show I think reading is going to be the
new hot spot for londoners this is a
good one that's managed to just fall
into place so hopefully we should secure
a fantastic deal
[Music]
thank you
I think that view went really well I
think obviously with the vendor
situation they just want they went out
with that property on the basis of that
I feel as though they're going to accept
the offer it's been on since November he
said he's not had many viewings he wants
professional People Like Us who were
able to actually handle something of
this and make serious offer so it's on
for 1.2 we've offered uh 1 million and
27 000
um so nearly a couple of hundred grand
Western asking but they're open to sell
one or both and we said we'll take both
off you for that I think yeah we're
looking around 160 on a refurb aren't we
yeah and then we can get some double
occupancy Flats going as well which is
just going to bump up our rental
valuation which is again going to help
commercially yeah nice work nice work
our team
so is this a HMO license HMO oh that's
good because that's what we're looking
to do so yeah brilliant brilliant if we
put this on their Market we want to get
refinance what do you think our end
value will be if we done this to the top
you know we've had a property for eight
bedrooms just down the road and I would
say that was over a meal on Twitter
in each room
yeah one yeah definitely be over a mill
this would need like a proper the
boxings yeah right yeah from what we've
seen so far what are we talking build
costs yeah there is quite a bit um
there's so many new flooring throughout
re-deck yep so full re-deck isn't it new
skirting some of the plasters blown it
probably gotta re-skim through it it's a
good size with potential obviously we
can't see some of the rooms because
tenants are in here
that's what my problem is you can't make
enough on something you can't see I know
it could be anything that can be on
those doors true
I mean it could be an offering principle
that's what we're looking forward at
this stage we're looking for an offer
no no you have an idea of the lowest
that he'd be able to go
today
um I can't discuss
but I can't guarantee anything yeah put
it to him and let us know yeah yeah yeah
all right thank you very much
it's got do you know what it is
potentially it's got good potential
around here you can tell because I'll
speak into that I mean the rent it's a
rental area so it would go is
[Music]
now it's just a waiting game the offer's
in proof of funds have been sent over so
it's just a case of waiting game I think
the vendor said they need to have to
talk to the family so we're just trying
to put a bit of pressure on just trying
to get it off at land so we'll get a
lockout agreement on it and make sure
that sales hours and no one else's
[Music]
we need to give it so it's going to need
what 150 Grand how much
160 Grand pumped into it to bring it up
to standard what we would like agreed in
principle today
620 Grand cash
[Music]
it's a long day it really is a long day
and it's hard graft you know finding
these deals is not easy they don't just
land on your lap they are out there
they're there to get but you've got to
work for them and you've got to know
your stuff I think the tiredness is just
adding up now I'm well used to manual
labor so it's actually a surprising to
figure out that I'll I'll tiring using
your brain is pressure at this point I
think the deal that we've got if they're
off Target in London they're not going
to get cash flow that we're going to be
getting
purchase price we have pretty much just
agreed on so that's 1.1 mil just waiting
for the agent to get back to us now
okay then they should accept from there
bye
[Music]
[Music]
so this morning we've had the offer
accepted so we're happy we're about to
pitch
had people
I'm feeling really good and I think
because the deal the numbers are really
good that's going to help naturally
there's nerves as well as excitement to
go on stage and kind of put something
forward but you know excitement trumps
all of it
I'm feeling pretty confident with the
pitch yeah numbers and just go in there
be confident be ourselves and translate
as calm as possible as
I remember my name on stage I don't mind
can we please give a warm welcome to
Adam Jody and shirelle
how are we all doing
well we are Samuel Lee's event how are
we all doing
thank you we've got an amazing brr to
HMO this was a six bed semi-detached
house we also bagged it in London like I
say it was run down wires everywhere
pipes everywhere I went in the attic I
was bang my head I know I probably I was
going to bang my head anyway but I was
bang mad every two seconds but what we
were suggesting within the refurb cost
was to stick a dormer on you know so I'm
not banging my head when I go up to my
bedroom it's an actual proper Loft
conversion as well we completely
re-plaster we change all the skirt and
archives we put the proper fire rated
doors on we get all the pipe work and
the cables all Behind the Walls and tied
it all up so these numbers I don't want
to labor on them but the purchase price
was six four two two five for the refurb
of 130 and a gdv which is an N value of
1.1 million so this means you can
effectively have a free house
yeah that does the clap
Hermos
chose Twickenham here
30 minutes away from Heathrow Airport we
are 20 minutes walk away from
underground six minutes away from the
Piccadilly line like it's just so it's
just such a perfect location for hmos
let's go on to demand so you want to
check the demand in that area I mean
when I went on spare room for this
particular location there was 1 000
people wanting a room guess how many
rooms there were available just 23 23
rooms available and a thousand people
wanting them like that demand is just
absolutely insane how
are you going to make this happen you're
going to make this happen by getting the
training you're going to make this
happen by using that education you're
going to make it happen by staying in
the community because that is the
absolute number one thing to keep you
afloat to keep your mindset focused on
what the goal is you're going to make
this happen because you've got knowledge
someone else has got time someone else
has got money you're going to join
Venture you're going to raise Finance
you are going to be bosses in the
property World okay don't watch TV go
and watch something about property when
you're reading read about property where
you're speaking speak about property eat
it breathe it sleep it and I guarantee
you in the next 12 months we're all
gonna clear
I think the last team did pretty well
the team that manages to get the best
response from you guys that gets the
most interaction and cheers and claps
that team ultimately is going to be very
likely to be the team that gets through
to the to the final round so please
welcome Adriana Martin Scott thank you
thank you Samuel
um so we're going to present to you our
deal which Lee thinks the best and is a
fantastic deal
it's a BRI to HMO and reading and we are
getting both of those properties
um if you can see it I know it's not the
clearest but basically there's two
basements here
um and we're going to convert them and
title split them into studio apartments
and then with the rest of the HMO which
is all this and what we're going to do
is convert it into a six bed HMO for
each property and basically they're all
going to be on Suites and
um
they are all going to get about 750
pound a month
and this is our property here and this
is a newish building and this is our
land as well so um what we're planning
on doing is uh building a property and
having three Flats in there the total
um cost of all that would be 220 000
including building legals everything and
the gdv would be 700 000 so therefore
give it giving us an additional 480 000
pounds profit on top of the existing
deal
[Applause]
on top of that as well
all right guys I'm going to start
bringing you through some of the
building costs so the kitchens that are
currently in are no good so we're going
to rip them out put new Swanky danky
kitchens in and we're also going to fit
ensuites in every single room it's not
expensive work so it's stuff that's
keeping the cost real really low down
and over to drive as gdv up as well at
the end
uh going on to the basement as you can
see from the floor plans we need
separate access to that so there is two
drives either side that is going to
allow us to use them drives to the
access to the basement so we've been
able to Achieve 300 000 pounds just by
doing a bit of paperwork basically which
is quite normally I think yeah that's
good purchasing the property refurb
legals everything is 1.3 million pounds
once you've refinanced this property you
can pull out 75 of the value this gives
you 1.278 million you are owning a 1.7
million pound house for 22 000 pounds
and again our clean profit number of 4
300 pounds every month after the first
five months so who in this room thinks
that so far this sounds like a pretty
good deal well there's a little bit of a
deal breaker
stamp Duty who's heard of it stamp Duty
on this property is 86 000 pounds
however we have managed to reduce this
figure by half which means we will only
pay 42 000 pounds stamp Duty we decided
to run our creative strategies and there
is actually a thing called multiple
dwellings relief which means that when
you're buying more than one property
under the same transaction you get a
discount okay so you've got the two
properties as they stand the current
hmos that's two we're then title
splitting the basement Flats which means
we can get a valuation of four
properties
who is excited about this deal yeah
everyone's excited about this deal
correct yeah yeah how would you think we
came to this deal do you think we just
tripped over it on right move
no list of all comes with graft you put
it whatever you put into this you will
get back out if you put 50 in you'll get
50 of the money you could potentially
get you've got to put 100 into this game
and until you get to somewhere like
Samuel's level and you're earning decent
money you need to learn to start
sacrificing some things if that's sleep
if you have to sacrifice sleep just sit
on right move and Google some things and
get get your knowledge going a bit more
you have to do that because property is
the way forward if you want to be
financially free
[Applause]
[Music]
I think we smashed it I really do I'm
really confident really nervous but I
think yeah we did did a good job I
thought we were a tough challenge with
the time constraints on it I think when
it gets to this stage the team don't
need to be led between the two of me and
Adriana we're both strong enough to go
off and work on his own I don't know
who's gonna go I'm really don't because
I just think everyone's amazing so
why am I stronger than Jody because I
retain information
um I'm actually accurate with any
information I'm going to produce and if
I'm not sure I'll go and find out before
I present it I don't tell little lies
I think she's good at sort of flapping
around quite a bit but maybe not so much
actually implementing exactly what she
needs to implement unfortunately I do
love him to pieces but I think
this link
so out of the two if if it was picked
between the two
hmm
I'd say I'm the strongest but I'd say
with them it's too close to call
I think Adriana spark a bit better on
stage
but that bit that would be it because
everybody's so close so you don't want
to see anyone go I feel like we're all
quite connected now and we're like
friends and fat it feels like we've
known each other years so it'd just be
it'll be really really emotional tonight
really emotional
there's been a little bit of conflicts
for me anyway moments where I've just
swallowed my tongue so you know if my
team's in the bottom two it's all coming
out
they keep telling me I'm too nice but
it's hard to hear because that's the
sort of person I want to be but business
is different when the chips are down I'm
gonna have to be something else and I
will bring that
foreign
[Music]
Challenge number three and two of you
will be evicted from this challenge
Adam's team you're a team leader I told
you to step up what happened Adam I
think we had a great time I led by
drawing out everyone's strengths and I
think it worked really well Scott you
and the team leader of this group how
did you get on as team leader yeah I
thought I did well I had a great team
behind me so yeah I thought we did
really well
was it you that found the actual deal no
I kind of pointed Us in the reading area
and kind of set as a formula to look at
the difference would you mean pointing
this in the wedding areas so um we were
obviously looking
um around London and we weren't getting
stuff to stack and then I kind of knew
about the
um Article 4 and the
um Elizabeth line come in so I thought
it'd be massive Capital depreciation
there who found the loophole with the
stamp Duty
um so that was
um Adriana but um obviously I was kind
of behind all the titles splitting a bit
like how Adriana found the property but
you were kind of behind her but like I
say I they've got talent and I'll Direct
on it question for you Scott what skills
and attributes make a good team leader I
think directing the team in in a
direction towards your goal lead by
example and good communication so why
were you none of those things
do you think leaders should step up yeah
I did stuff do you think leaders should
make decisions I didn't make decisions
okay so as a team leader who should be
evicted in your team
um I think it's very tight I don't think
that I think we all pulled away and and
I think that
um it's very hard to say who should be
evicted
okay I'll rephrase the question because
you can't handle that who was the
weakest link
I I don't think anyone in this challenge
was the weakest link
of our team I think I was a very good
leader I think if you ask the team I
think they'll say that as well Adriana
so who was the weakest link Scott why
um it's it's difficult I think everybody
really pulled the weight but I think a
big part of this challenge is
the public speaking aspect and I think
in terms of how you can build rapport
it's got a team leader so we told you
the weakest link you've got to say for
yourself
so obviously I'm more introverted than
anyone here in terms of that so and
that's probably why she's saying that
um I believe this deal wouldn't be as
good as it was if it wasn't for me so so
I believe I'm in the on the key aspect
behind this deal I think the reason
Scott wouldn't say who the weakest link
is because he couldn't say Matt because
Matt's done the whole refurb and I did
Great Value couldn't say Adriana because
Adriana found the property and so
without saying himself I'm just
wondering what you actually did
I did a lot of stuff I I basically like
I said I pointed Us in the dot in the
right direction and I I work really hard
if you find deals anywhere by just
saying reading might be a good area I
mean come on but my expertise that I had
the vision behind the building as well I
did all the six bed on Suites the the
commercial valuation the title splitting
my knowledge basically made that deal
how did you get on with your team
hustling what did you think of the guys
well I was really excited to hear who
was on the team all three of them are
really strong
but I was quite shocked when I went into
the room because they wasn't making any
phone calls I felt like they were
wasting a lot of time yeah no I disagree
with that um we were making calls I
think a big part for me was that we
needed to have a rough idea of the patch
we did one at some level of due
diligence just for the fact that it was
going to be a HMO we needed to know it
was going to be Article 4 could just
ring blindly you know but once we'd
established that we were hitting them
hitting the phone quite hard do you know
what the issues with their team is they
find it really hard to take advice
how did you get along with Shira we got
along fine we got along great and did
you get along with her
we have different ways in which that we
work so we was doing our best to ensure
that as a team we were moving forward
but for me I felt like there was times
where
um Jody's idea was more on what she
wanted to achieve rather than that group
thing so it did take some time to kind
of come back to where we was all on the
same page
from what I've looked at it looks and
from what husband said it looks like the
invite is just potentially on the high
side but he's very confident on that in
value yeah
who viewed the bedrooms we couldn't view
the bed bedrooms because the tenant
wouldn't let us in how would you feel if
I come to you with a deal and said hey
ah great deal I haven't viewed the
bedrooms though if you told me it was
subject too and I had a 14 day cool
enough period and we arranged the time
to see the to see the rooms I'd be happy
with that it's a shame I'm disappointed
in that it was time constraints I mean
we can go there tomorrow but we needed
to get this wrapped up
I'm pleased with it why should you stay
in and finish why should you not be
evicted because I've LED I've LED well
I've stepped up I've taken the criticism
as hard as it is to hear I've taken that
and I've run with it
so overall I think you did a good job
both teams however we had a vote
from the audience
after you did your presentation about
who was the strongest team and we
basically thought we'd let them decide
and they voted everybody raised their
hand for the for one team raise hand for
another team we count with the hands
raised and after the vote you wouldn't
believe it
but it was a draw
[Music]
so the only way we can do this if we're
going to evict two evictions is to evict
one of each team
[Music]
the winner of the eviction the person
that's going to get 20 000 pounds Hard
Cash needs to be somebody that knows how
to communicate sell fight their way it's
got to be a case of just who can fight
their Corner the best in in the
boardroom so I'm going to give you each
you know just sort of 20 seconds to say
why you shouldn't be evicted and who you
think should be evictive
[Music]
Jody I should have been evicted because
we wouldn't have a deal if it wasn't for
me uh the other team members didn't do
the due diligence before carrying out
um a deal so there was actually an
article four areas we wouldn't have a
property we wouldn't have a presentation
if it wasn't for me so I think I'm a
very strong strong candidate because I
was carrying out what you needed to
carry out to make sure that we succeeded
that's incorrect because it was your
role to kind of look at the permitted
development and you looked at that and
you said that yeah it's been done and
then later when we was here it was
actually no it doesn't have a HMO
license and that was what was because
you had the Nimbus and you was looking
at that and certain questions and he was
adamant that C4 meant they had planning
I said no it needs to be have planning
after seven occupants
say previously and then that's happened
several times throughout the um
throughout
from my team yeah Jody
Adam who's the weakest link on your team
dirty why do you think both the people
voted job
I don't know shirelle's really good with
numbers off the top of the head I'm not
I got a calculator I don't need to do
that and because she's such a dominant
character that's why I think it and
obviously Adam's going to stick up for
himself as well but I do believe that
I'm a strong character because I am the
one that got the deal I'm the one that
put the presentation together I'm the
one that guided them to say let's do the
number no but I guided you as to say
we've had 620 on the table and then you
went outside and took the call and come
back and said oh with a note on the
paper we've gone to 640 and I was like
well hold on that was up without
checking with us or anything so that did
happen and then I had to take the phone
and speak to the agent because every
time you went outside to have the
conversation you was just going along
with what is that they were saying and I
had to say to you no I didn't know we
are the ones
you know what you do these small little
ones I don't even know if you're aware
that you're doing it and then just
because people ask you a question and
like you just said because I'm a
dominant character I think that's
bothering you so much I said all right
you've gone to 640 it's fine we've made
a mistake we learned go with 642250 and
now you're saying they're going with
your deal but that's still the number on
the table which is what I said after
trying to clean up your message
as well so that's why I say that you're
the weakest on the team
Matt who's your Victor
actually one person yeah out of the team
it will be Scott just based on the
presentation and the conference side of
it yeah because I feel like even though
I wasn't team leader every team I've
been in I've always tried to carry me on
and read them all in the team and I've
brought something to every single aspect
of every single challenge whether it be
knowledge on actual legislation rules
through it tomorrow's or whether it be
pricing jobs it's not easy Scott for me
because Ricky Ricky doesn't think he did
a great job leading Adriana and Matt
have said you need to go so unless I've
got a really strong reason otherwise I
mean help me out I think they're just
saying that because they're scared of of
my ability so I've won both tasks so far
Adriana's probably thinking she's the
only other person apart from me that's
done that same with Matt is probably
thinking another lad's got to go he's
probably picking me because I'm working
with him so I think they are scared I
think I think with that no no listen I'm
talking you're veggie talk yeah so
um I think without my vision then this
deal wouldn't have happened without my
direction this deal wouldn't have
happened they can say as much as the one
but I've got the most knowledge I made
that deal I honestly believe in that
challenge I don't want it to come down
to I know more I know more it wasn't
about that it was about what you could
bring to the table I feel in that
challenge I excelled I was probably
another dog coming into this and I think
please no but I did it and I pulled my
way no you did not carry me I carried my
way every step of the way I found the
deal I negotiate I think in the
presentation today I absolutely excelled
and showed I can publicly speak and I
can deliver and that was part of the
challenge I am 100 confident that I've
carried my way through this process and
I should be here I think Scott I mean I
think you're a good businessman I know
you've done BR deals yourself Adriana I
think you did Excel I think your public
speaking was incredible unfortunately I
have to evict somebody I do think that
in this challenge you were probably the
weakest so I'm really sorry Scott you're
evicted thank you thank you cheers thank
you you two are good so you can go
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
why did you hesitate
I had to think about that
what do you think who's the strongest I
think I'm the strongest me
I think you're all three very strong
contestants and I have no doubt you're
all going to go really far I can see
firing in Jody I can see fire in
cherrell I can't see quite the Sound
fire in Adam and the big reason that I
don't show a lot of fire is because of
my size is something in my life that
I've had to deal with when I have shown
fire sometimes it's become too
intimidating well in the business world
the more fire the better believe me I
don't know what you want me to do I
don't want me to scream the house down I
don't know I know I'm trying to be
direct here no I'm just I'm just saying
I can see a lot of passion in Jody and
shirelle I can't see it quite in you I'm
not a big screamer that's not my
character yeah I'm still telling you
exactly why I think I should be here
I've brought so much to this like I've
started from here and now I'm here and
every single challenge I'm raising the
bar just a little bit more so I'm
becoming a better person from this
channel there's no reason why I should
go if you can give me a really good
reason why I can go please tell me
really really difficult decision for me
three extremely strong contestants I
think shirelle you've got through well
so you're going to be staying in the
challenge so well done you can go back
[Music]
between Adam and Jody you're both very
different Adam
you've really had to step up and you've
shown a little bit of weakness in the
past I do feel like you've LED well and
I can see Improvement Jody I can just
see such a fire I mean I sense you're
going to be a multi-millionaire
and I'd love to to be part of that and
to help see that happen
I am gonna have to make one eviction and
it's it's it's a it's a sad one
Jody you got a lot about you Adam
I think your speed of growth is good
Jody's got a little bit more backstory
in property
[Music]
I'm really sad to say I have made my
decision Adam you're going to be through
to the next round Jody I'm sorry you're
evicted
oh
kind of felt like that I supported my
team and stood up for my team and they
kind of threw me under the bus because I
know I'm doing more than everyone
outside of it they know that that deal
wouldn't have been anything like it was
if it weren't for me like and then the
only thing that let me know was his
presentation
and that is all we said
I've got enough friends I don't need any
fake friends so if I'm asking them
throughout the challenge you know is
there any more I could do as a leader
did you join any more from me in the
saying no you're perfect I couldn't ask
for more off your and and then to go in
the boardroom and say otherwise I think
you know snakey sort of move so his
actions were brilliant through the task
amazing really good
he fought him but when it came to
presenting himself in front of an
audience
of it all you want yeah you've still got
to push push exactly
[Music]
Adriana doesn't know as much he said she
does she can speak well she's got a law
degree but in terms of anything property
wise if it went for me in that challenge
I know how to price up the job I know at
all the technical stuff about it I
pointed them in the right direction to
see we're carrying you
upset me especially as a woman
Matt same sort of thing as a builder
obviously got a good gift of the gab I
thought I'd win so in terms of anyone
else winning I don't know I think the
bet the best person lost
foreign
[Music]
have you guys actually sorted out what
your plan is or are you being led by
your investor you don't want to go in
there with nothing
what's this based on where's the proof
of that I'm helping you to make this
deal firm firm it up the landlords come
back in effect to change their mind
you know what we call that stupid I wish
I'd have kept Scotland I think Scott
would have raised the money
I'm bitterly disappointed we think about
winning and that's it you're evicted
[Music]